bad jokes and dad jokes abound as
alleged SNL comedian Pete Davidson mocks
of veterans injury with no consequences
and I get kicked off of Twitter for
telling a dad joke
we will analyze the comedy double
standard with funny man extraordinaire
oh and Benjamin he's actually my
consultant on getting deep platformed on
social media then a millennial writer
whines and the pages of Vice that he has
been disenfranchised from voting in
Tennessee merely because he's not
eligible to vote in Tennessee also he's
committing insurance fraud
finally a look around the races on the
last day before the midterms
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael an old show I knew I'd get
banned from Twitter at some point I just
it was only a matter of time I figured
it might be something that I said that
was incendiary or controversial or
politically incorrect no no no no it was
foretelling a dad joke we will go into
it and precisely what got me D
platformed and why Jack Dorsey is a big
jerk but first let's make a little money
honey let's talk about zip recruiter so
you know I've talked about zip recruiter
for a long time there are job sites that
will tend you send you a ton of wrong
resumes to sort through that's not smart
there are job sites that make you wait
for the right candidates to apply to
your job that is not smart
what is smart is using your relative
what is it what is also not smart rather
is using your relatives to fill in at
work while you're looking for snip for
staff what's not smart is you know
making the lottery the centerpiece of
your retirement plan didn't work out a
couple weeks ago what's not smart is
letting your friends pick your karaoke
song go to zip recruiter they will make
this much easier for you zip recruiter
comm /m k s they will find you the right
person it doesn't depend on candidates
finding you it finds them for you it
actively goes out you post the job it
will go at it will find candidates it
will invite them to apply it will send
them to you it's why it's the number one
rated job service by employers in the
u.s. this rating comes from hiring sites
on trust pilot with over a thousand
reviews right now my listeners can price
it for career for free at this exclusive
web address zip recruiter dot-com /mk
s that is zip recruiter comm slash MKS
zip recruiter comm /m K s do it
don't waste time don't waste money time
is money honey go to zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire I'll have missed
you all have missed you all the last few
days usually I get to talk to people
over the weekend on Twitter and this
time I couldn't by the way I've never
been more productive in my entire life
not being on Twitter is unglazed freed
up so much of my time
they have kicked me off the reason that
they have suspended me because I could
get my platform back in two seconds all
I have to do is delete the offensive
post eventually I suppose I'll have to
but I'm resisting for now they want me
to delete a post and it would it's wrong
I don't want to delete it the post that
I tweeted out that that created so much
trouble was this it said quote remember
Democrats don't forget to vote on
Wednesday November 7th haha how do you
get it cuz election day is Tuesday
November 6th but I said Wednesday
November 7th haha get it this is one of
the oldest jokes in elections people
have told this forever ton of lefties
told it and by the time I was kicked off
had not been kicked off but then I even
went further I went further to show the
punchline of this joke because I
suspected they might use this as an
excuse to kick me off so I added to that
tweet the addition to that tweet said
quote specifically of course I mean
voting in this poll which will be open
until Wednesday November 7th should
Twitter ban or suspend conservatives
over election jokes thank you Jack
Dorsey and Twitter for proving my point
for proving my exact you couldn't have
done it any better I go I log onto
Twitter and so I told this joke and
nothing happened for 24 hours the the
time I got kicked off of Twitter was
when Donald Trump jr. retweeted
something that I had sent out I'd
criticized CNN or something like that
Don jr. retweets it almost immediately
I'm kicked off of Twitter a full day
after I send out my election joke and a
ton of other of the same election joke
all up on the internet mean here's SNL
made a similar election joke in their
coverage here they are
can't wait to vote so we'll see what the
polls next Thursday Tuesday I know mom
kidding it was not funny so be part of
the victory get out there is SNL gonna
get kicked off of Twitter is us and I'm
gonna get kicked off of youtube for
telling that Jeffords saying oh that's
on a different day ha ha it's on
Thursday it's on Wednesday it's not on
Tuesday of course not a ton of blue
check marks head tweeted out a
Republicans don't forget to vote on
Wednesday ha ha ha and they had not been
blocked so we block me i log into my
account and it says quote your account
has been locked we have determined that
this account violated the Twitter rules
as a result we've locked your account
what rule did I violate can anybody show
me the rule that I violated because I
looked through the Twitter rules there's
no rule that I violate there was one
blog post that talked about misleading
during an election but what it was
talking about was misleading who you're
representing if you're representing a
campaign or a political party or this
obviously I'm not representing any of
those things but it so specifically it
didn't say you can't make election jokes
but of course we know that because they
didn't kick off the left
they only kick off right-wingers or use
it as an excuse so at this point I'm
kicked off some of the Daily wire guys
start a free Knowles hashtag so it gets
a lot of posts very quickly so Twitter
finally responds they won't respond to
my appeal it would they will nyah peeled
that ruling and I said look I actually
explicitly say I explicitly underline
the punchline to the joke which is a
poll about kicking conservatives off
Twitter I actually you should I mean
even you shouldn't kick people off for a
joke but even in this joke I'm
explicitly not talking about the midterm
elections they won't respond to my
appeal but they responded very quickly
when we started pointing out all the
left wingers who made the same joke they
deleted their posts they deleted those
posts they would rather censor a handful
of leftists then stop censoring
conservatives absolutely outrageous
so they've kicked me off of Twitter at
some point I'll have to take down the
post in part because the election will
be over so there's no reason to have it
up anymore but and Twitter also already
took down the post but they will not
respond
this is targeted this is a ton of bias
and the question that we need to ask
these big tech companies like Twitter is
does their interference constitute
election interference does their
interference their censorship of
conservatives over left-wingers so close
to an election is that an in-kind
contribution to Democrat candidates is
that interference I think we should hold
them to account I think we should burn
their bank accounts down to the ground
if they're violating election law
because that certainly seems like what
they're doing
are they publishers or are they
platforms are they publishers or
platforms they say they're platforms
they behave like publishers they say
they're open and anyone can use it and
the rules are clear and then they start
selectively unfairly targeting people
with whom they disagree politically and
kicking them off right before an
election if their publishers treat them
like publishers and burn their bank
accounts down to the ground now
obviously I'm having a little trouble
processing this I haven't been kicked
off of Twitter before fortunately though
I have someone who is well acquainted
with getting kicked off of social media
platforms be very funny
oh and Benjamin is here my consultant on
getting kicked off the Twitter thank
goodness I have my Twitter band
consultant oh and Benjamin here oh and
thanks for coming on I still have me
brother yeah I'm here to help you
through your transition I was previously
a platformed American yeah trans and D
platform B flat you've been deep depth I
have been depth I'm really good I'm glad
to that you're here because I mean
you're an expert in comedy I was kicked
off of Twitter for making a really
incendiary violent oh no it was a dad
joke yeah I made a dad joke yeah and
then I got kicked off and a bunch of
lefties made the same joke they stay
down well they'll kick you off if you
kick a sacred cow even if it's not their
guy but I was banned for life for making
fun of david hog and that's when i
realized there was something seriously
going on with that kid yeah i've made
fun of david hog i haven't well maybe
not on twitter though i actually don't
think i've ever made fun of him on tour
I was pretty relentless and then when
they when they realized they realized
how they could get me which is so ironic
to the leftist disposition in Hollywood
yeah cuz I said anybody that isn't old
enough to grow pubes can't tell me not
to have a gun which is a
they said I was sexualizing a minor he
was about to be 18 and that's not
sexualizing a minor
they are sexualizing minor just well you
lost your career because you refused to
sexualize - because of the trans kid
thing yeah yeah and people don't believe
me so amazed I may read emails CA right
yeah it's kind of a little blah but like
I do it they fired James Woods they
fired James Wednesday fired and it's the
heart of darkness there's that the me -
movement in a conference room as they
were representing up that's right so you
know there's that but yeah I refused to
or I was I was calling out this dude who
had a five year old boy that he was
saying was a girl and he was gonna put
him on hormone blockers and stuff I'm
like that's a that's abuse hiding in
plain sight you know that the people can
be broken up between like abusers people
that sit by and watch and then people
that don't sit by and watch it's kind of
what the what the world is broken up
into and they get real mad when you when
you don't let him eat the baby that's
really this come on I'm a little hungry
that is how the elections gonna break
down and this the fact that they kicked
me off three days solidified his I as by
design it is by this yeah because you
know if they I think they kicked me off
cuz it wasn't what I said I said
something I made some joke about the
election that everybody makes and then
they kicked me off the next day right
after Don junior tweeted something I
said making fun of CNN and it was right
then they almost immediately kicked me
off
isn't it a bad look for them though to
kick off conservatives blue check more
conservatives two days before the
midterm elections you surprised how many
people don't notice because that's one
of the one of the the great things and
weaknesses of conservatives is usually
we have jobs and families so it's like a
lot of people don't they can't tell
unless they're listening the podcast you
know they're just like looking and
working and dealing with families you
know a lot of leftists are unemployed
you know just just childless childless
you know
warlocks and witches they're just
running around doing spells and stuff
panting you know you're joking
witchcraft abounds right now they're
there and I'm I am NOT speaking about
some fringy thing voxcom encouraged
left-wingers to practice witchcraft
everyday feminism encouraging people to
practice witchcraft this is John Podesta
wasn't it didn't he have some spirit
dinner or something yeah and I just
introduced my wife who's here to some of
these emails and she would like this
last week because some of this stuff I
missed
yeah i've just been coming out of my
office like amy they're witches they're
actually witches and Orko's is pepra
lunch something weird is happening in
Haiti you know because I don't like
going down to conspiratorial rabbit hole
so you can't prove but the ones that are
just right there like they have parties
where they cut up a cake that looks like
a human body and they're like how is
your flesh tasting I'm Hillary and
they're like mm-hmm and they think
that's normal
yeah they're like we're taking strength
from it I'm like dude most my buddies
are like truck drivers and plumbers and
stuff but no one's like not holy spirit'
dinner snow that's hedonic treadmill
like your whole life that's like you've
run out of sins and you just have to
invent them yeah you're almost tempted
to practice virtue because you've just
run out of sins
it's like adrenaline man I turned down a
murder this morning and I feel like I
can't feel my face oh yeah I've been
faithful to my wife for the days now I'm
so high off it so so it seems like
everything's going well for you it is I
know it's fun being off Twitter actually
clears your head a little bit
this is what I've wondered because you
you've been thoroughly d platform you're
still on YouTube yeah I'm on YouTube and
then they took away my live-streaming so
I started another channel and it was up
to you know like two thousand people
watching within like a week that's the
thing is they keep trying to to get rid
of people and all it does is solidify
your base it's really it's having the
opposite effect it's kind of hilarious
to why this is what I think is they
think they kick you off Twitter they
kicked me off Twitter and then the
audience goes away and then nobody hears
from you ever again but then you
up again and immediately you get your
whole audience back this is what I think
is gonna happen in the midterms this is
what I suspect is happening we have been
told 0% chance Republicans are gonna get
blown out in the house don't even vote
it's not even worth it yeah I think I
think I'm very optimistic
I know Clavin freak both of us everybody
keeps texting me he's like he's now
become been used text me all this
pessimism but being like a comedian and
just never bending the knee I get to see
a lot of perspectives like it's never
the people they say are against
Republicans it's never did these big
voting blocs in fact a lot of times it's
the opposite it's always these leftist
weirdos that are literally eating human
cake flesh they're like ah the Jews hate
Trump and meanwhile all these Israelis
are emailing me like we love that dude
meanwhile Israel is building Trump a
train station in Jerusalem literally and
they're not against political
correctness stuff it's only white girls
from your alma mater I know I know it is
they're ruining the entire world there's
a white millennial girls they all and
they have some Ivy League degree
certainly yeah and they're offended on
behalf of every other person on earth
literally they're like well I have a
made-up friend whose friend is black and
Jerome doesn't like it Kevon and that's
the thing is they always treat them like
the worst stereotypes of what they're
trying to defend that's right they're
like they can't read so that isn't very
nice of you that you're like they can
read you can read they do this on voter
ID they say we can't look Michael we
can't require IDs to vote how people
can't get idea exactly like I think they
can't I'm pretty sure black people are
entirely capable of getting ID in fact I
think they have IDs I've been I've been
to bars with black people
I've been tobacco I've traveled on
airplanes I didn't get IDs if they stop
importing them yeah I think you'll see
Hispanic people start weaning right oh
yeah I already do that's why they lien
laughs just because they get a new crop
of illegals yeah right they're like what
we'll give you a card if you vote for
this which and Hillary's like
abrakadabra and and that's the thing
it's like people assume that my wife was
on the left because she's half Mexican
and I'm like her whole family's on the
right why would you assume that no right
it makes no sense
I'm really tall don't play basketball
I'm not black stereotype you know this
this actually what you've just said your
wife she makes me really grateful for
America it is the American dream
it is the dream the American nightmare
being married to Owen Benjamin sometimes
but just a brave woman but it makes me
really grateful and this this reminds me
of operation American gratitude Oh tell
me more I don't know if you've heard
about this operation American gratitude
I really like them for two reasons one
because then we can make a little money
honey moon do you know that but also
they do excellent excellent work this is
the opposite of witchcraft operation
American gratitude was started when the
founder heard of Vietnam veterans say on
his podcast that he had never been
welcomed home in 50 years since
returning from Vietnam so operation
American gratitude you could you go you
get a box you'll get your own kit it'll
give you a bunch of thank-you cards for
veterans and interview a veteran Carter
you are not forgotten card a Pio WMI a
card a 58 to 20 card that's the people
who were lost in Vietnam for those who
made the ultimate sacrifice and what's
more 100 percent of the profit from
Operation American gratitude goes toward
building the freedom never sleeps
business training center in beautiful
Eagle Idaho
I love Idaho I love I love eagles okay
all right
it's an on-site six month paid
entrepreneurship training program
designed for veterans and
underprivileged youth you can make life
better for Vietnam veterans and you can
also instill a sense of gratitude so
that your kids don't grow up to become
the screeching awful millennial America
hating people gratitude really is the
antidote to witchcraft it is and you're
like oh thanks for this coffee she's
just be like and she just melted you
just a puddle of something that bill of
you like cannot drink opal like they're
just so gross anyway how do people know
that you know the way that you can find
out that I sent them yeah is if we go to
raising Americans calm slash cough fa ce
o-- v fe fe get your operation american
gratitude kit you will get a twenty five
percent discount for this week only in
honor of Veterans Day coming up you can
make Vietnam vet
lives better help your kids learn some
gratitude for less than 20 bucks
as always partnering alongside Operation
American gratitude makes you fifty
percent more likely to meet George
Washington in heaven well guaranteed any
veterans and will you be great grateful
if they do this I will be
extraordinarily grateful if they do this
because because this is the great thing
about a rising tide lifting all ships an
American productivity you helped us you
helped the show you helped get a message
out you helped Vietnam veterans you
helped little kids the only people you
don't help her those witches which you
don't want it how do I want to help them
no wholly not so go over there raising
Americans calm / co' FFA that's right
you should go over there too I will
absolutely good go over there
I might spoke offa wrong I'm enough to
google it I know this is that I think I
picked the worst promo code I think my
I've lost about 50% of advertising
revenue it has I picked a word that is a
misspelling right it is my definition of
misspelling what's the best promo code
you think you could use Oh real quick I
do have to address the Eagle situation
yes
cuz we live in Washington and we have a
bunch of chickens and a bunch of dogs
and a bunch of eagles and at first I was
like god Bless America who knows you
guys fine and then there'd be like five
and they and I just it's now just
dislike border wall situation with the
chickens where I just keep trying to
like keep the because the Eagles are
huge and they'll just come down and be
like you just let them in they're not
gonna hurt the chickens no they just
want a better or henhouse they just want
it to work in the henhouse
they just want to just come over to the
henhouse you know we don't don't even
check what species they are they doesn't
matter
nice little caterpillar those talons and
that giant sharp beak are just randomly
there are you trying to tell me that
just because Guatemalan authorities
arrested seven human smugglers in the
caravan those Eagles are trying to do
your chickens harm who's to say what
rape is yeah that's that's gonna be the
new postmodern book I think that's like
I say well you can always tell someone's
up to no good when they're trying to
redefine monstrous terms like that's the
biggest red flag ever it's like well
yeah yeah like see what happen was Rome
it up with Polanski with other
celebrities murder
remember Whoopi Goldberg was like well
it wasn't rape rape it wasn't rape or it
wasn't real rape right yeah so when
you're trying to make these distinctions
you back away yes we're just back away
it's like no I'm a centrist rape guy I'm
kind of in the middle you know I like to
get along with everyone no come on I'm a
moderate I'm not an extremist just what
I'm saying okay I'm not gonna take an
extreme position on that yeah it's like
she said no but there weren't several
exclamation points come on keine you
know I actually do I want your opinion
on this from the comedy perspective okay
which is okay so they they've been D
platforming people they're there they
take extreme voices away whatever my
extreme voice of telling dad jokes fine
right
did you see that Pete Davidson joke on
SNL I did you saw him he if we do we
have it the Pete Davidson he's they're
making fun of this combat veteran and
practicing witchcraft practicing which
almost certainly yeah here he is cool a
Dan Crenshaw you may be surprised to
hear he's a congressional candidate from
Texas and not a hit man in a porno movie
so there he is looks like a witch was
engaged recently to a wit a witch I'll
do another who said God is a woman and
having a super colty video okay yeah
there's broom only parking right outside
of SNL it's really it's really efficient
it's good for the environment you know
it only so crazy to think about this now
I was arguing with people on Instagram
which is my new Twitter I've made it
just toxic I know I'm with you this is
actually what bring that he was like oh
oh ins got great Instagram posts and is
I'm only there because I got kicked off
Twitter that's that's remarket that's
why there's stocks keep tanking but
someone was saying well he made fun of
his dad who died in 9/11 so why can't he
do that I'm like that was his pain to
mock yeah and also if it was that dude's
friend that would be one thing right but
someone who clearly hates you for your
politics and is making fun of something
that happened you in a war that's a
different swing like you can do a joke
about rape versus mocking a rape victim
yeah you never tell a joke about a rape
victim who's like you know especially
one who's in the public eye who's you
know especially I mean in this case is
even crazier than that because this guy
got his injury serving that witch survey
that dude trying to provide exactly and
he it was like his third deployment as a
seal or something right it was like he
just kept going the extra-mile and this
this little weasel and uh like okay
because someone was telling me they're
like oh you've done a pedophile joke I'm
like it was it was a pun about a
pedophile like it's about me going into
uh you know like a drug store being like
we're the pedophiles and I know the
whole thing is is it's like well my
toenails are wrong it's a it's a long
joke but it's a pun and they're trying
to compare that to that that that actual
pedophile directed guardians of the
galaxy and I'm like no he's just saying
he wants to have sex with children like
that's called being a psychopath not
even a joke yeah yeah and I'm starting
to really wonder if people have lost
their any morality at all like they
don't see the difference that's the
thing is while you're eating chicken and
I'm eating a baby what's the difference
the difference you're a hypocrite you're
because they're they're calling
conservatives hypocritical over this for
saying oh you know you're criticizing
this joke they somehow don't see the
difference how do we get it through them
I don't think you do I think you just
kind of we just focus on our gratitude
mmm and and just let this guy just keep
just practicing witchcraft and we just
got a win that's why we got a vote
that's true we just got a barium have
you voted yet I haven't yet I'm gonna
I'm gonna drive people to the booth but
according to a tweet it's uh what was it
the seventh the eighth right well I
forget what it they're gonna shut our
stream down they're gonna the minute I
say this joke the minute I say this dad
joke they are gonna shut down this
stream they're gonna say Michael is
inciting violent hateful bigoted rules
breaking rhetoric that was the other
thing but you have farrakhan's on their
conscience termites calling Jewish
termites in saying death to America
death to Israel they also didn't tell me
what policy I violated because there is
no policies nopales well that's why I've
been telling this to people for a while
that you got to stand with everybody
getting be platformed even if you don't
agree with them cuz exactly right
because appeasement just means you could
eat and last yep and so what they do is
they have one's called bullying or one's
called ah I don't know but I'm like
that's all comedy so it's like knock
knock who's there it's like home
invasion statistics sadness now you mean
to me and you're like okay so now my job
is exaggerating
exaggeration and hyperbole irony like I
can't do it if I don't do that so
they're just just waiting to ice me they
would ice me if they did if they knew
that it wouldn't create the opposite
effect that's true and if they weren't
going to abolish ice
they're really getting caught in that
you know my rhetoric is I know it's like
[ __ ] it's like oh so you're for ice it's
like what do you mean you mean the
existence of a nation no no no no not be
you know I largely doctrine I don't
think we should enforce laws no no no
city well this is my sanctuary Hank I
know Yeah right now you're in my
sanctuary cave and bora-bora I think you
know yeah this is w CIA black ops yeah
all right
oh and I got a kick yet no you're the
man what at work and people find you
where have you not been blacklisted Oh
huge pianists calm to get to get tickets
to my upcoming tour or my last special
persona non-grata shot in Atlanta a shot
all right and make sure to follow oh and
on the dwindling list of social media
platforms that will have him
you're still on Instagram I'm on
Instagram but Facebook gives me 30 day
bands they let me back for one day and
then they kick me every time every time
well exactly Birds playing this little
game of cat mouse with me it's really if
yeah well I just bought a drone so we'll
see what happens let's not threat by the
way the shows not it's right it's not a
threat all right
I'm gonna say YouTube later bro this is
why we bring in social media D
platforming consultants to really make
you feel better when you get kicked off
of them
so speaking of very funny things a vice
writer a writer in vice.com has
inadvertently published one of the
funniest columns of the entire midterm
elections if this millennial who is
extremely angry that he was not allowed
to vote in Tennessee and the excuse the
reason why he wasn't allowed to vote is
that he's not eligible to vote in
Tennessee and he's very upset about this
the the headline is quote what it feels
like to be disenfranchised by a voter ID
law the guy's name is Davis a Winkie
that can't be his real name but maybe it
is his real name Davis Winkie is what it
says on the article subtitle
I had a birth certificate a photo ID and
utility bills proving my residency but
Tennessee decided that wasn't good
enough okay well it sounds pretty
interesting
he's got the ID he's got the proof that
he's a Tennessee resident Oh
hey let's I'm with you let's see maybe
these laws really are discriminatory
maybe they're really preventing you from
oh no not at all it's just total
nonsense he goes on to write quote you
had to have either a Tennessee state
issued ID or a federally issued photo ID
in order to vote my wife and I were in
this strange situation of being young
and married but still somewhat
financially dependent on our parents our
vehicles were registered in our parents
names and we had George driver's
licenses registering the vehicles in
Tennessee would have incurred a pretty
significant tax burden and getting a
Tennessee driver's license we were led
to believe by our insurance agents would
be a problem for us since then we'd be
listed as drivers on our parents cars
without Georgia licenses so we were in
this space where we feared losing our
transportation or having to incur a
significant financial burden if we tried
to get Tennessee driver's licenses I
know that was a gobbledygook of words
let me try to to summarize that for you
he didn't have a Tennessee ID the law
says you need to have an ID from
Tennessee or from the federal government
he had a Georgia ID why because he was
lying about his residence so so what
this means is one he was committing
insurance fraud because he's saying he
lived in Georgia and drove in Georgia
when he didn't he was living and driving
in Tennessee also I think he may have
tried to rectify this right before the
election but there are cut-off dates for
registration so he missed his shot sorry
too bad try again next time then he says
we were in my wife and I were in a
strange situation of being young and
married but still financially dependent
on our parents unfortunately this is not
a strange situation anymore a lot of
Millennials do this I think the the age
now to go off your parents cellphone
plan is about 65 I think that's the
median cutoff it means that you're a bum
get off your your parents finances
you're married you're an adult start
acting like an adult stop being a little
child stop committing insurance fraud
stop blaming everybody for your problems
they're your problems I get it look I
sometimes forget deadlines I forget
paperwork okay blah blah blah fine you
miss the deadline and you didn't even
just miss the deadline to to register as
a Tennessee res
and get your car insurance and
everything pushed over you chose not to
do it cuz you didn't want to pay taxes
you didn't want to pay fees you didn't
want to be an adult okay
fine but that's your fault you're a
child and children don't get to vote
adults vote not children now I think the
left is trying to lower the voting age
to 12 or something but they actually are
trying to lower it to 16 in certain
places but your your if you're gonna
behave like a child you're gonna be
treated like a child and you don't get
to vote if you want to be an adult and
you want to stop committing insurance
fraud and register where you live and
stop having mommy and daddy pay for
everything for you and your wife then
you can then you can vote because then
you're behaving like an adult it's
unbelievable and to even the language
that Millennials use listen to this we
would have to incur a significant
financial burden if we tried to get
Tennessee driver's licenses you mean you
would have to pay the taxes and fees
that you legally are required to pay
because you move to Tennessee nobody
made you move to Tennessee you could
live in Georgia you still should have
your own car insurance but nobody made
you you chose to do it but now you won't
accept the consequences for your actions
this is the best they've got because the
other argument and we were talking about
it with Owen the other argument against
voter ID is a racist argument they say
that black people can't get IDs they
can't black people have IDs they have ID
cards they can go they can go vote they
can go buy alcohol they can go travel on
airplanes they can buy cigarettes you
need IDs for a lot of things in life in
the argument from these white liberals
who choose to be offended on behalf of
other people is that black people for
whatever reason aren't capable of
getting ID cards they are white
Millennials might not be capable of
getting ID cards but other people can
don't be offended on behalf of other
people don't don't put your problems off
onto other people we've got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube we have
a lot more coming up I want to give my
final thoughts on the midterm elections
because my gut feeling on this is a
little different than what the pollsters
are saying before we do that I have got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube I
probably already have that probably
kicked me off halfway through this show
what I've got to remind you though is
that we're gonna have a backstage
tomorrow starting at 8 p.m. Eastern Time
5 p.m. Pacific we're gonna be hanging
it's gonna be the god-king Jeremy boring
been drew Alicia myself we're gonna be
covering all the latest election news as
it happens
and we're actually gonna be getting
Twitter updates from our own Cassie
Dylan and Colton Haas why we're letting
Colton do anything I have no idea why we
would subject ourselves to this but it
should be a lot of fun you're not gonna
want to miss it
and Cassie and Colton are gonna be on in
the throws of social media while it's
happening I obviously can't do that job
because I keep getting kicked off as
always daily wire subscribers get to ask
the questions so make sure to subscribe
today also don't miss Andrew Flavin's
next chapter of another Kingdom
performed by none other than little old
me almost certainly the last acting role
I'll ever have in this town today
subscribers get exclusive access to
episode six entitled he bought me if
you're not a subscriber you won't be
able to watch new episodes of season 2
until Friday so what are you waiting for
go to daily wire.com and subscribe to
watch the first and second seasons of
another Kingdom again none of that
matters this is what matters because
right now
Never Say Never who knows Democrats told
us we were gonna have a blue wave
Democrats were gonna take the whole
Senate they were gonna take the House of
Representatives they're gonna do all of
this stuff now it's not looking like
that is it now it's looking like maybe
they won't take the Senate now it's
looking like maybe Republicans will gain
in the Senate now it's looking like they
might not get 50 seats in the house they
might not get 40 seats in the house they
might not even take back the house can
you imagine what the tears will taste
like they actually we probably will need
a new vessel because it's just gonna be
a block of salt like those thick blocks
of salt that you've grilled meats on
that's what it's gonna come out that way
they're not gonna have any more tears
left to cry it's just gonna be pure salt
popping out you're not gonna want to
miss it go to daily wire come get your
left just your Stumbler we'll be right
back
all right the midterms what do we think
about the midterms Nate silver tells us
87 percent chance I think he's upped it
to that the Democrats take the house
history tells us Democrats are gonna
take the house Obama lost over 60 House
seats in his first midterm Clinton lost
54 I think in his first midterm Bush
didn't lose any but it was right on the
heels of 9/11 in America was pretty
unified behind that President Reagan
lost a bunch in his first midterm it
goes on and on and on okay Mike Pence
says he thinks we're gonna keep the
house here is a Buckeye I think we're
going to expand our majority in the
United States Senate and I think we're
gonna hold our Republican majority in
the House of Representatives that's what
he thinks
now I talked to my pollster friends they
say one in 1,000 chance Republicans keep
the house but I talked to my Politico
friends the ones on the ground the ones
who were in the fields they say
Republicans are gonna keep the house my
gut tells me Republicans are gonna keep
the house I know that the odds are so
slim when you look at all the numbers I
would if I were to make a bet on this I
would want some of those good Shapiro's
odds you know I'd want him to give me
another one of those four to one odds
and then I would then I would put money
because I'm looking at the data I get it
but my gut tells me something that this
is not a typical midterm election my gut
tells me president from hasn't lost
votes my gut tells me Republicans can
keep the house by a slim majority or
maybe they lose it by a slim number but
that's what my gut is telling me right
now another reason I'm thinking this is
that the Democrats are going fluffy
they're going really really fluffy
they're not hard-charging at the end of
this campaign leaders CNN talking to
they're at a rally for Andrew Gilliam
socialist gubernatorial candidate in
Florida and they interview just a random
person just a random woman at the end of
the event to get her take on the race
you're there one voter here this really
is personal will Barack Obama's presence
this race in here today influence your
vote I believe that it will we picked
her randomly out of the crowd but at the
end of our interview when I finally
asked her name it sounded strangely
familiar what's your name Oh No oh my
god you're kidding you you the woman who
is here at this exclusive area of the
Gilliam campaign rally you the woman who
looks like Andrew Gilliam because you're
his mother
you you you're his mother oh my gosh wow
what a coincidence so tell me like how
great is your son I mean is he like he's
super great or he's just like really can
you imagine if they were at a trump
rally and I don't know they they were
talking to Tiffany Trump they didn't
know his Tiffany and she said oh you
know yeah I think Trump is gonna do well
and you know actually I'm his daughter
I'm Tiffany Trump thank matters are
biting her head off they do you know
it'd be this awful segment but its total
fluff that they're going into this with
and I think it's fluff because one they
don't have anything to run on and two
they're nervous I mean SNL did that
sketch they actually got this pretty
right which is all the Democrats saying
like oh we're we're looking forward to
the election we're confident blue wave
ha ha ha you know beads of sweat pouring
down their face they're very nervous
because by all historical rights there
should be a blue wave election they
should win the Senate and they should
win the house the polling doesn't quite
suggest that they're also in trouble
right now because prominent Democrat
candidates are really really kooky I
mean Andrew Gilliam puts on a good show
but he is a socialist he's a radical
radical candidate and this woman in
Arizona
Kyrsten Sinema is a badess kooky as they
get and there are several others like
her here cinema martha mcsalley has
asked you to apologize shiver when she
said was treason his comments about
somebody being able to go and fight
Caliban do you regret that statement at
that time you know Martha cross the line
with those comments and that's the
choice that she's made in her campaign
to run a campaign that's based on but do
you regret that statement though at all
what was an offhand comment during an
interview about a war that I believed
was misguided and still believe this
misguided what Martha's chosen to do is
run a very negative campaign based on
false attacks and smears and lies and
that's her choice but I think Arizonans
are choosing the person that they
believe shares their values and they
believe you stand up for that so just to
translate that from gobbledygook what
she just said is dive dive dive I'm not
gonna rescind my comment and her comment
was during the Afghanistan war the early
stages she said it would be perfectly
fine for Americans to go fight for the
Taliban and martha mcsalley obviously
said what no you can't do that that's
awful that's treasonous and she won't
even walk that back she won't even walk
back her pro-taliban comments and she
this kind of reminds me a little bit
during the tea party election there were
some kooky Senate candidates none ever
as kooky as this woman I mean none ever
like that no one ever said that
Americans should go fight for the
Taliban but but it's like the bizarro
world version of the Tea Party during
the tea party election we had this woman
a Christine O'Donnell was running for
Senate and speaking of which we were
talking about witchcraft with Owen she
there was some allegation that she
practiced witchcraft and she came out
with this ad this insane ad and said I
am NOT a witch here she is I'm not a
witch I'm nothing you've heard I'm you
none of us are perfect but none of us
can be happy with what we see all around
us politicians who think spending
trading favors and backroom deals are
the ways to stay in office I'll go to
Washington and do what you do I'm
Christine O'Donnell and I approve this
message
I'm you okay
not a great ad not a great campaign from
Christine O'Donnell but I would like to
point out the difference between her and
Kyrsten Sinema Christine O'Donnell
said I am NOT a witch Kirstin cinemas
comments to say that Americans should go
fight for the Taliban is the equivalent
of running an ad and saying I am a witch
I'm a witch hi I'm Kirsten cinema I am a
witch yes I am exactly what you've heard
everything you've heard is true I'm a
witch so I get you know it was a bad ad
from Christine O'Donnell but at least it
was angling it's something good you know
it was her defending herself and saying
no I'm the good thing not the bad thing
Kyrsten Sinema and other Democrats are
saying no I'm the bad thing I'm the bad
thing open borders abolish ice Americans
should fight for the Taliban that that
is a big difference
so it's this bizarro world version it's
it's bizarro world Tea Party two because
one it's the midterm right after a
controversial presidential election and
because Democrat voter enthusiasm is
very high the the reason it's different
than the Tea Party is one because
Republican voter enthusiasm is also very
high and two there's no issue that
Democrats are running against they're
running against a guy they're running
against Trump because Trump is mean
allegedly and says mean things but
there's no issue you know in 2010 that
election was about Obamacare this awful
law that took away our doctors that
destroyed a sixth of the economy that
took away our freedom to make
life-and-death decisions and gave it to
government bureaucrats it was a
referendum on that and so GOP enthusiasm
was high and Democrat enthusiasm was a
low now they're both very high and I
think this is gonna have a significant
impact here there was a there's a guy
Tim Ryan who is now running away from
his party on key issues because he wants
to win his house seat he wants to run
away from the party to try to save his
own seat you're seeing a lot of
Democrats do this around the country
that doesn't speak well for a blue wave
yours
Tim Ryan you know you're seeing
proposals out there like Medicare for
all you're seeing abolish ice raise
taxes do you agree with these proposals
and what is your platform well I you
know I think these are principles you
know first of all I don't know a whole
lot of Democrats that are talking about
abolishing ice I come from Ohio you
don't know how are you kidding me
most prominent Democrats running for
office in this country are talking about
it you had Ocasio Cortez made it a big
part of her platform Democrats used her
as a major fundraiser Beto
O'Rourke was talking about it Liz Warren
Lea Wafaa was talking about everybody
was talking about abolishing ice for at
least several weeks there during the
summer now they're trying to walk it
back because it's obviously deeply
unpopular with the American people so
you've got Tim Ryan there one lying he's
saying they're not running on abolishing
ice they are but he's running away from
his party imagine if in 2010 Republicans
were running away from opposition to
Obamacare if they were interviewed they
said oh I don't know if we need to
repeal Obamacare no I haven't heard I
haven't heard a lot of Republicans
talking about repealing Obamacare no
they wouldn't have a one you need
momentum you need to have a platform
that you're hard charging and running on
Democrats don't have that which is why
I'm really skeptical of the conventional
wisdom right here I was looking at some
of the breakdowns and Real Clear
Politics has a good breakdown because
they take all the major polls and
average them out right now according to
rope their politics and this was as of
last night it could have changed in the
morning the GOP has 218 solid seats a
Democrats have 205 solid seats and there
are 38 toss-up seats of those 38 toss-up
districts 26 of those districts voted
for Trump regardless of whether they're
represented by a Democrat or Republican
26 of those toss-up districts out of 38
voted for Trump so 26 to 12
Trump versus Hillary it actually seems
to me that in just just looking at
numbers and districts the GOP has a raw
edge here the Democrat advantage is
historical and it's not to be
understated I mean this is it it would
be history shaping history shattering if
the Republicans held on to the house
here or even if they didn't lose that
many seats but we're in history-making
times we're in really strange times
right now this is not a typical midterm
election right now they're looking at
some of the highest voter turnout since
1966 now you can you can't even take too
many lessons from night
1866 because the Democrats owned the
house for decades and decades so you
didn't see the house swaying between
Republicans and Democrats at that time
not until 1994 not until the Gingrich
revolution did Republicans finally
retake the house after decades so you've
got the highest turnout since the height
of the Vietnam War after the Kennedy
assassination massive civil unrest said
the civil rights movement all of these
things I mean you are in historically
unparalleled times you can't make those
comparisons okay look at the rhetoric
now so the rhetoric that they're
employing at the last moment right
before the election Paul Ryan and House
Republicans want to talk about the
economy Donald Trump wants to talk about
immigration one of the reasons to temper
our hopes that Republicans keep the
house is there it seemed to be blaming
each other for why they're gonna lose
the house
so Trump seems to be blaming Ryan and
Ryan seems to be blaming Trump okay
they're not really touting how they're
gonna keep the house much anymore
Paul Ryan era of Mike Pence where is but
other people are not as much but look at
those two approaches Paul Ryan saying
talk about the economy Trump saying talk
about immigration by the way Trump is
talking about the economy a lot too but
he's not shying away from immigration
Trump is right here Trump is right and
Morning Joe and Paul Ryan and Mika
Brzezinski and all of the Brooks
Brothers set is wrong here is the
conventional wisdom care of mourning Joe
Donald Trump is not completely destroyed
the Obama recovery and they would think
that and could get a lot more votes but
Donald Trump has reminded them of
Charlottesville every day over the last
couple weeks and what does that do that
inspires Democrats independents moderate
Republicans suburban Republicans to vote
Democratic Wow in May he's reminding
them of Charlottesville he's saying
because Trump is talking about
immigration he's reminding them of a
white supremacist killing a woman I
don't I don't see the connection but
then again that's morning Jo for you
what he is saying is Trump should keep
his mouth shut
on immigration on cultural issues and
should only talk about the economy
nobody is motivated to vote in midterm
elections especially when your party is
in the White House
because of the economy or because of
401ks that's just it does not happen
that way the reason that there's a
reaction to the party in the White House
is because the if the Republicans are in
the White House then Republicans are
happy they're not as motivated to go out
and vote and a marginal upswing and the
Dow Jones is not going to cause them to
go out and vote whereas the party that's
out of power does have high motivation
so they go out and vote and they take
the house okay how many times has the
elite media and Morning Joe and the
Chamber of Commerce Republicans how many
times have they told Trump stop talking
about immigration
Trump's for talk about immigration since
he walked down the escalator since the
beginning of his presidential campaign
and he wiped the floor with every other
GOP candidate 16 17 candidates mows them
all down because he was talking about
these issues that people care about that
are foundational that our cultural that
are essential politics is downstream of
culture the economy is downstream of
culture for that matter and so run on
the economy sure but run on these things
too it's the only way that you're going
to be able to rally support from your
base when you're in the White House for
the midterm elections that this is my
that's my gut feeling my gut feeling is
we're gonna be in for a lot of surprises
it could all go wrong there is some
polling that shows that better o'rourke
is neck-and-neck with Cruz I don't
believe that polling for a second I
think it's polling designed to
manipulate public opinion I think Cruz
is gonna be fine but Republicans have to
go out there and vote the reason you
have to go out there and vote is because
we will bathe them leftist years and it
will be absolutely delightful but I
think we could be really in for a
surprise I think it will be close
elections but the sum total of all those
close elections could be excellent news
for Republicans and we'll see what
happens tomorrow we'll have a few a
little bit of last-minute analysis
tomorrow and then stick with us during
all the coverage okay until then I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show I won't see you on Twitter
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018